البدايه من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت
10 مسيرات في هجوم روسي الليله الماضيه
على جنوب الشرقي البلاد كما افادت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه في بيان لها بشن اكثر
من 32 هجوما متبادلا بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه خلال الساعات الماضيه
في المناطق المحيطه بمدن كوبيانسك واليمان
وبخموت ومارينكا في مقاطاعتي دونيتسكو وفي
مقاطعه
جنوبيه البلاد اعلنت الاركان الاوكرانيه
[__] 13 موقعا وتسعه مرابض مدفعيه روسيه
وفق البيان وفي الشرق والشمال الشرقي قالت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان كافه الهجمات
الروسيه في
مقاطعتيك باءت بالفشل من جهه قال موقع
ريبار العسكري الروسي ان القوات الروسيه
سيطرت على مواقع وصفها بالاستراتيجيه في
منطقه برخوفكا شمال مدينه باخموت واضف
الموقع ان الجيش الروسي يواصل هجوما مضادا
في اتجاه سد برخوفك المائي مشيرا الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه جددت هجماتها على مواقع
الجيش الروسي في منطقه كليشيفكا جنوب
ضخموت وان معارك عنيفه تدور هناك وفي محور
كريمينيا
قال الموقع من الجيش الاوكراني دفع
بتعزيزات باتجاه بلده نوفو سيلفوسكوي
شرقيه الايمان في محاوله لوقف تقدم القوات
الروسيه
في غضون ذلك اتهمت القوات الروسيه الجيش
الاوكرانيه بقصف مدينه اليوشكي في مقاطعه
خرسون بقذائف حارقه من نوع غير معروف وقال
ممثل عسكري عن اللجنه تحقيق الروسيه ان
حيا سكنيا في المدينه تعرض للقصف باستخدام
قذائف المدفعيه غير معروفه ما ادى لاحتراق
منزلين بالكامل وفق قوله مشيرا الى ان
خبراء متفجرات يشاركون في التحقيقات للكشف
عن طبيعه تلك القذائف